what happens when the lights go out for  example in hurricanes or tornadoes or  ice storms what happens to society we  have lots of data to show that  24 hours after lights go out  about when people miss their third meal  you know the glue that holds society  together starts coming unglued and uh  and uh you know when the society just  starts very quickly disintegrating we  can test this stuff through simulators  we have seen it tested and  and nuclear detonations of the past and  we have  real world experience every year from  hurricanes hurricane sandy hurricane  katrina you go back and you look at what  happens to society and this is just a  small scale thing when you have these  blackouts that affect regions and  they're only temporary  imagine  if you had you know a phenomenon that  would black out all of north america for  a year you know we can't afford to take  an emp hit and expect to survive we've  got to harden our critical  infrastructures